this episode is brought to you by incog
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion if you haven't been paying
attention to the news headlines you
might have missed the drama that rocked
the tech and AI industry for a week
breaking news uh related to open AI
Steve kovak joins us now this is a
stunner uh in some respect Steve yeah
Sam Alman is out as CEO of open AI we
just got this announcement it's a script
even Hollywood would die to write a
superstar CEO on one side a disg grunt
board on the other caught in the middle
were 770 employees and the future of
artificial intelligence it wasn't
another major AI breakthrough but a soap
opera of sorts all occurring within the
company open AI the same company that's
behind chat GPT their CEO Sam ultman was
abruptly fired from the company's board
on November 17th the news stunned
everyone in the Tech Community but what
immediately followed was pure chaos
replacement CEOs were being appointed
almost daily and there was an internal
Mass Revolt from employees if you're a
keen viewer of this channel you would
know that I've covered open AI a lot
I've even done a whole biography on
samman's life but for those of you who
are unaware he's the co-founder of open
Ai and a very prominent figure in the
tech industry he started a global race
for AI dominance even surpassing some of
the largest companies out there so when
Sam was suddenly fired then rumored to
move over to Microsoft and then returned
all within a matter of days everyone is
left scratching their head
what happened here one of the reasons
might even be AGI artificial general
intelligence one of the Holy Grails of
all of technology so let's get into
[Music]
it you are watching T Fusion
TV imagine that you're Sam ultman you're
in Las Vegas enjoying the festivities of
a Formula 1 race on the weekend you're
in your hotel room when you get a link a
Google meet link it's from your chief
engineer and a board member Ilia satova
but as soon as you join the video call
you realize that something is very wrong
all the other board members are there
except for your close friend and
co-founder Greg Brockman they tell you
in a matter of minutes that you're fired
from the company they don't give you any
clear reason just some vague accusation
of dishonesty then they hang up and then
you're locked out of your computer this
is how it happened for Sam Alman on
November 17th 2023 but he wasn't the
only one Greg Brockman another
co-founder was also demoted but asked to
stay at the company Brockman was so
outraged that he decided to quit on the
spot the board appointed Mira morati the
CTO as interim CEO she was the only one
who knew about the plan
beforehand the news was soon to be made
public in a blog post the board said
that Sam was fired because he quote was
not consistently candid in his
communication with the board end quote
they didn't elaborate any further
leaving everyone to wonder what really
happened behind the scenes was it a
hostile takeover a corporate Coupe how
could the board fire someone so
influential without any warning or
notice part of the answer lies in open
ai's unique corporate structure and
there are some other theories as well
but we'll explore that in the next part
of the video but let's see what happened
next the news caused a huge uproar in
the AI community and Beyond Greg
Brockman tweeted his support for say and
his disappointment with the board many
people joined him including Microsoft
CEO saana Dela Microsoft is open ai's
key partner and has invested $13 billion
for a 49% stake in its for-profit wing
since they didn't have any seats on the
board Microsoft had no say in the matter
they could only watch from the sidelines
inside open AI however there was
pandemonium employees demanded more
clarification but the board remained
tight lipped meanwhile rumors circulated
that Microsoft had already extended an
offer to Sam and Greg to join their
ranks and establish a new AI research
team Sam's supporters were ready to jump
ship and at the same time they were
plotting his return in a surprising
twist the interim CEO Mira morati had
turned her back on the board and joined
team Sam over the next few days with her
help ultman met with the board the next
day to discuss his possible return the
meeting went on late into the night and
the verdict well Sam was still out the
board did not have a change of heart
that was everyone on the board except
ilas sukova in a surprising twist the
architect of Sam's dismissal himself
made an unexpected u-turn on the Monday
he expressed regret for his
participation in the board's actions and
aligned himself with Sam talk about a
role reversal by then the board had
already appointed EMT Shia former twitch
CEO as the new open AI Chief EMT himself
was surprised and pledged to bring
Clarity to the situation he was going to
initiate an independent an investigation
to find out why his predecessor was
terminated in response to the new CEO's
appointment
747 of 770 employees sent a scathing
open letter to the board they
collectively issued an ultimatum you
resign or were all going to join
Microsoft in this fluid turbulent
scenario the open AI headquarters stood
deserted devoid of anyone there was no
sign of a clear resolution on the
horizon
as the tech World watched most people
thought that this was going to drag on
but then suddenly Sam ultman got his job
back on the 22nd of November only 5 days
after he was fired open AI announced
that they reached an agreement with Sam
and they had a new board too Sam posted
on his ex account that he was excited to
return to open Ai and continue the
strong partnership with Microsoft Greg
Brockman also came back into the fold
announcing his return with a picture
except for Adam D Angelo the old board
members had all left they were replaced
by Brett Taylor the former co-ceo of
Salesforce and Larry Summers the former
treasury secretary EMT Shia who was the
interim CEO for just 72 hours seemed to
be happy with the outcome judging from
his tweet so just as abruptly as it
started the 5-day long Saga ended with
Sam ultman back at the
wheel now the major question is why did
the board fire their CEO in the first
place
the answer is complicated and murky
there is no official explanation only
rumors and speculation so far but based
on some reports we can piece together
some possible factors please keep in
mind that this is just the situation at
the time of
writing the board claimed that they had
some disagreements with Sam about how
the company was run and also that Sam
wasn't always truthful to them this
seems like a bit of a weak reason to
fire a CEO who was negotiating a deal to
sell shares to investors at a whopping
$86 billion valuation that should be a
big achievement for any company but open
AI is not a typical company it's a bit
different to the other Tech Giants out
there I've explained these aspects in
more detail in previous videos on open
Ai and Sam ultman so I'm not going to
repeat myself here you can check out
those episodes if you want to on the
channel but in a nutshell open AI was
founded in 2015 as a nonprofit with a
mission to create artificial
intelligence that would benefit Humanity
at its formation it had a celebrity team
of Founders including Elon Musk musk
would leave in 2018 due to a conflict of
interest since then Sam ultman has been
leading the firm he established a
for-profit arm that raised billions from
Microsoft the main reason was to fund
the expensive research and development
for their AI
models Sam ultman was in charge of the
for-profit section however the whole
firm was set up in such a way that the
nonprofit faction had the ultimate power
and it was controlled by the board
members
this odd structure left Sam and
Microsoft at the mercy of the board and
they were skeptical of corporate
expansion besides Sam ultman and Greg
Brockman other board members included
Ilia satova we've already mentioned him
quite a few times now he is a prominent
researcher in the AI field and is very
vocal about AI safety then there's Adam
D'Angelo a former Facebook executive and
co-founder of Kora there were other
notable names on the board it would seem
like there's an ethos struggle within
the company does open ai go all out and
try to make as much money as possible or
do they stick to their core value of
making AI that will benefit
Humanity Sam has a knack for spotting
Trends though he's been working on some
other side projects that were beyond the
reach of open AI safety conscious board
one project that raised some eyebrows
was worldcoin it was a crypto Venture
that used eyeball scanning technology
and was marketed as a potential solution
solution for AI induced job losses a
stepping stone to Universal basic income
he was also toying with the idea of
launching his own AI chipm venture to
reduce the over Reliance on Nvidia he
reached out to Sovereign wealth funds in
the Middle East for a potential
investment in the realm of tens of
billions of dollars additionally he
pitched to SoftBank group another
multi-billion dollar investment this
time in a company he planned to start
with former apple design Maestro Johnny
I the focus was AI oriented Hardware
these projects were seen as distractions
by some of the board members they wanted
their CEO to focus on open Ai and its
core mission to escalate matters even
more Sam found himself in conflict with
sukova who formed a new team in July
within the company dedicated to
controlling future quote
superintelligent AI systems the dispute
reached its boiling point in October
when according to a source familiar with
the relationship ultman made a move to
reduce sova's role in the company fast
forward to November 6th it was the the
day that open AI hosted its first
developer conference in San Francisco
Sam ultman made several announcements
regarding customized versions of chat
GPT it's going to enable users to make
task specific chatbots these custom gpts
might operate independently in the
future that's a major red flag for
safety concerns these announcements were
the last nail in the coffin they had had
enough Sam was going too far and for the
rest of the story we know how that all
panned
out
and the last reason a possible AGI
breakthrough according to Reuters an
additional concern may have been
simmering within the company the report
suggests that some staff researchers
penned an internal letter to the board
cautioning about the discovery of an
advanced AI with the potential to pose a
threat to humanity these researchers
flagged the potential danger of this new
model in their letter but did not
specify the exact safety concerns there
has been been no official statement from
open AI regarding these letters but they
did acknowledge a project called Q
because first I need to be real with you
it is very hard to know right now what
qar actually is we know from reuter's
reporting that according to their
sources it may be some kind of powerful
artificial intelligence Discovery at
open aai the company behind chat GPT and
that there are fears it is so powerful
it could threaten Humanity
that sounds really dramatic but this
discovery was apparently alarming enough
that at some point after a group of open
AI researchers took their concern to the
board like oh my God are you all aware
of what this company is working on the
CEO Sam mman was fired now it gets a
little murky here but some believe that
this project could be the highly
anticipated AGI or artificial general
intelligence which is capable of
outperforming humans in any economically
viable task the day will come when the
digital brains that live inside our
computers will become as good and even
better than our own biological brains we
call such an AI and AGI artificial
general intelligence it was a step
towards artificial general intelligence
I know it sounds complicated but simply
put it's artificial intelligence that is
more powerful than humans now open AI
staffers believe that this could
threaten Humanity so some of them wrote
a letter to the board this could also be
the reason for the firing of Sam Alman
in my personal opinion I would be
shocked to see this I would think
something like this would be at least 5
years away but who knows what's going on
behind the scenes but anyway just over a
week ago ultman hinted at a significant
breakthrough during a summit in San
Francisco was he alluding to this
discovery no one knows for sure with
generative AI falling into the hands of
ever more people there's bound to be
more junk emails and spam calls it
doesn't bode well for online security
and this isn't to mention data Brokers
right now your personal information is
being sold online without you even
knowing it this information can be used
to send unsolicited content sell your
browsing habits and even commit identity
theft if there was only a way to stop
this from happening this is where
today's sponsor incog comes in they can
delete your information from the records
of data Brokers on your behalf all you
have to do is create an account let
incog contact the data Brokers and then
let let them take care of the rest to
get started and protect yourself online
use the code cold fusion at the link
below to get 60% off an annual incog
plan go to incog docomo Fusion to get
started okay now back to the
video all in all in the end it appears
that Microsoft and samman are the
biggest winners in this whole debacle
ultman will continue to lead the company
now with a board that is in theory more
more supportive of his vision is this
going to be good or bad for the rest of
us we'll have to wait and see SAA nadela
has also voiced his support however the
power tussle and internal drama don't
exactly bode well open AI is the company
that started the generative AI
Revolution they're supposed to set the
standards while this industry is in its
infancy AI can be a dangerous tool if
used wrongly so governments and policy
makers are watching this is not the kind
of spectacle that you want onlookers to
see for people like us it's just another
episode of drama a tad amusing and a
smidge terrifying I say terrifying
because in ilas sata's regret tweet Elon
Musk replied this quote why did you take
such a drastic action if open AI is
doing something potentially dangerous to
humanity the world needs to know and
that's kind of true if open AI has
indeed created something dangerous
behind the scenes that paints the
chaotic week in a totally different
light so what's your take on this feel
free to share your thoughts in the
comments I'll also leave the biography
of Sam ultman in the description and at
the end of this video so anyways that's
about it from me thanks for watching my
name is toogo and You' have been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next episode cheers
guys have a good
[Music]
one
cold fusion it's new thinking